se venissero sera ci sarà nuovamente qui
su sneak tve che il gioco dove bisogna
rubare le cose passiamo alle livelli e
case grosse tipo questa le cose grosse
più grosse che questa qua the man show
né su di caccia al lavoro del ladro è
facile un cazz.o che sia ragazzi abbiamo
fatto appunto home invasion e bank e io
andrei su free lo yacht suoi 8 tanto
sono tutti e tre normali
intanto il più difficile quello dove
devi rubare il diamante che l'ultimo
quindi facciamo agli altri prima a ok
perfetto infatti dice un ragazzo sono
arrivato io sono arrivato con un
motoscafo di dubbia provenienza con dei
dettagli ma devi avere quanto 100.000
dollari prima di andar via va bene e per
caso cade in acqua nego bene no era solo
per capire allora ragazzi tutorial su
come derubare uno yacht
il number one sono ruba in uno yacht tra
l'altro questo c'è in uno yacht
porca [ __ ] però c'è dalla nonna
veloce cioè valerci e vabbè mi piacciono
gli uomini armati come facce scappa è
anche incappato lui è impossibile un
iphone su cassetti 150 dollari
[ __ ] televisore bene 2.000 dollari
che veramente ma questo vale avendolo
avuto cazzo ma posso sulle armi
ma veramente ma allora mica è più facile
fatti vedere presente dove sei
mi dicono che non ce l'ho al parkinson
quando sparo
anche da ubriaco dove su carta quale
come è morto va bene
terzo non stiamo a ridere tanto di con
muore la gente più che altro rubiamo
qualche perfetto il bacio che fanno un
sacco di soldi facciamoli solo quando
servono gli scontri a fuoco perfetto uno
swatch quanto vale
non lo vedo perché tutto sul bianco
perfetto ok 31 perché posso prendere la
tua di arma perfetto cazzo
no vissuto fuori sono un [ __ ] sono
un [ __ ]
ma come ho fatto a chiudermi fuori vi
ricordate dei veri organo e steve coll
primo gioco del genere che ho fatta ecco
in confronto questo qua è impossibile
una pizza classic microwave pisa 8 64 78
64 7 lettore mp3 non ti 647 non
dovrebbero arrivare perché non hanno
visto perfetto bye bye bye veloce veloce
i ragazzi mancano 60 mila dollari
e siamo a posto vai vai vai di ovaie
veloce sono
chi è che cazzo ne sono fatta non ci
credo vai più di quanta gente qualsiasi
mi di fare un salto riesco forse non ne
sono sicuro c'è un fucile a pompa dio
sia lodato miglia attorno più ubriaco
che riccò allora credo che il fucile a
pompa sia nettamente più forte anche al
televisore al lavoro anche visto credo
che sia più potente questo che il fucile
ak 47 credo è ok dove cazzo entro va a
fan culo perfetto spero che non abbiano
sentito lo sparo ma credo di no dove
vado dove vado non ci arriva a 100 mila
dollari sta nave non c'è niente che vale
100 mila dollari
stavo scherzando dai lega non ho ben
capito se prima mi hanno sparato da qua
dentro o da fuori non ho capito mi
chiamo di cazzola vista ne sto colpirlo
porca [ __ ] prova a entrare lo stesso
non so se riesco poi cipro perfetto
acqua ce n'è un'altra quindi passiamo
sul retro fantastico e meraviglioso
bene allora quella era la password e 86
47 mi chiami corona che più
c'è gioco di me [ __ ] porca di una
[ __ ] foggia lercia porca eva lercia
[ __ ] piatta bastardo se non ci sono
100mila dollari solo laden trova ammazzo
va ammazzo
è crepa porca eva
ma tanto non possono trovare anche
volendo saltano in aria pon qualcosa ma
come [ __ ] ma allora non va la sede
stronzi ma dai ma prometto 647 o
perfetto solo 50mila a ok amica che mi
stavo girano già le palle bene allora
abbiamo tutto ve lo dobbiamo a verde un
solo uscire chi che cosa ci fanno dei
documenti di banca qua spiega mi devo
solo uscire
c'è devo tornare dove rory davvero prima
anto ria che non è così facile prova beh
tanto so già chi tanto non ce la farò lo
so chi non ce la fa lo so che non ce la
faccio corri corri forest carri ma no
mica legami che a rega 12 anni per falso
livello incredibile se non fosse stato
per il cavo ci avrei nel culo in una
maniera incredibile
allora ragazzi passiamo al successivo
the collector che questo dovrebbe essere
cosa vuol dire the collector tipo museo
dove rubare 600 mila dollari cos'è sta
roba
ma lei ragazzi 600 mila dollari di roba
proviamo vedere se riusciamo a fare
qualcosa ma qua è chiuso
ovviamente
impotente al suo troppo piccolo porca
eva e finestre grosse più grosse dovevo
fare perché fanno le finestre piccole
tipo una reggia merito salve ma lei non
ha le pistole mi picchia con la torcia
va bene torcia versus martello torre
versus lanterna verde ha vinto lanterna
verde
mi spiegate come cazzo si è possibile
che con una torcia mi ha buttato giù in
tre colpi e io col martello no come
prima c'è adesso cos'è spa una a caso
sto tizio ma non posso dargli un colpo
forte in testa dove tutto bene sparito
non nessuno c'è una pistola e vabbè
quanti siete
non mi hanno visto ragazzi mica sono
super stealth ok questo momento ria
dovrebbe essere più power
prendila però perfetto ok miccia che
botta il trono di spade ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi va a posto
ok questo valeva l'arca [ __ ] da mai ma
[ __ ] mammi chiamato tirato una spa
data come fai a 1
ok ragazzi mi sono scassato un cazzo lo
faccio tutto di corsa e vedo che
succedere che provo allora questo lo
prendo questo lo prendo adesso noi
principale tanto non c'è nessuno prendo
tutto a icona come non detto
segue l'importante che non hanno le
pistole senza le pistole non riescono a
prenderli mica se solo fossi usain bolt
best ladro ever cazzo merda vero il
porto scherzavo
non puoi prendere la spada che è
successo mi ha cacciato ma come come
accasciato va a fan culo ma dai non ci
voglio
non a caso livello stava andando bene ci
mancava solo questo parevami che se non
quando non riescono a prendermi fanno
crescere il gioco grazie al cazzo che
vincete voi
ok questo l'ho preso cazzo perché ma dai
ma sei stronzo
no ragazzi non ho parole ma perché mi
cresce al gioco porca eva era l'unico
dove potevo prendere tutte le cose in
corsa ma niente mi cresce al videogame
adorava affanculo niente ragazzi
facciamo dimension cambiamo perché non
va a giudicare da quanto tempo ci sta
mettendo a caricare deve sempre
grossissima ecco infatti dalla porta
principale deduco che
ok no era aperta la porta della serie
entra pure che ti spariamo in faccia
però vabbè è la madonna che cazzo è ma è
veramente così [ __ ] questo tipo scalare
fantastico in the gates stealth ok dall
entra or cazzo offrendola allo scasso
con l'albero posso scala veramente
perfetto grandissimo sono quasi sono
quasi arrivato al tetto rega perfetto se
una di queste finestre fosse aperta mi
che sarebbe il massimo della vita
problema per quelli pensano che sia
d'altra parte quindi fantastico niente
non riuscirò mai a entrare da un
soggetto è invece c'è il balcone
perfetto non avevo visto fantastico ci
siamo mai fatelo rubare il 250 ma ce la
posso fare
tanto ormai erano già in allerta quindi
chi se ne frega vai vai vai zio vai zio
rise veloce quanti colpi c'hai gli store
caricatore maledizione va bè ragazzi
proviamo un approccio molto più easy
tipo così subito forte sega
cazzo
che pistola giocattolo miglia della
chicco st pistola vuoi bellissimo mela
mettono col silenziatore no ma che cazzo
serve se entro che fa il fantacasino non
posso tipo c'è un piano di sotto non
nuovo visto vai vai vai vai vai perfetto
ovviamente tutte le porte aperte ci
mancherebbe poi ci sono i lingotti dott
ma tutti i lingotti d'oro con la porta
aperta [ __ ]
vabbè va bene ha dato non è casa mia va
bene così c'è condotto d'areazione forse
forse posso darlo nicchia solid snake si
apre dove che siamo a sono in casa sa
che bomba
ok a caso ma com'e va bene va bene va
bene non se ne sono accorti va bene
ragazzi gli seminati non so neanche come
va bene così non facciamo domande
chitarra di elton john
perfetto ok ragazzi il momento della
verità o lo butto giù o non ce la farò
mai più perfetto perfetto vai ok ok
calmi calmi cani 12 non ci posso credere
bene non c'è ancora nessuno cos'è sta
roba cibo per pesci va per arrivare a
quanto 250 ce la posso fare forza per
chi estesa ponente non valgono 100 mila
dollari
un tentativo regalo ce la farò mai più
ad arrivare qua lo sapete vero www sente
un cazzo vai non c'è un cavo anche in
stackhouse amica enorme vai vai grazie
grazie grazie
mangia un perfetto perfetto o vedi che
c'è un codice allora cos'è 53 42
perfetto ricordiamo ciao ragazzi 53 42
ci deve essere un cavo da qualche parte
lo sapevo che sarebbe stato sorvegliato
lo sapevo trova schiavo 53 42 53 42 dove
capsule game console
cos'è sta roba ovviamente tutta sta roba
come sempre me la sto infilandole le
mutande perfetto ok deve essere qua
ragazzi perché c'è il coso dell'allarme
perfetto
posso uscire acqua ricordiamocelo tutta
cassaforte dove dovesse a casa forte
maledetta forse ce la faccio anche senza
ragazzi siamo 220.000 228 eccola 53 42
ringraziali denuncia ancora l'alzheimer
no invece a quanto pare ciò l'alzheimer
dai che ci sono riuscito a fare attacco
non son riuscito ad aprire la cassaforte
ma se mi manca pochissimo perfetto ci
siamo mai come esco come escort
di qua eh sì quale 5 antichissimo
minchia parkour si le case e 250mila
dollari paky e abbiamo messo la madre vi
ammazzo la madre o il cazzo mi sono
bucato le ruote semi a guardà semi
mirava in testa ero morte potevo
veramente lanciare il monitor dal
balcone va bene ne ho fatti tre n 1 e
dilata ero riuscito male crashato 15 dic
azzi e va beh qualcosa che suoli smic
tiff finisce qua per oggi è stato il
quanto istruttivo anche oggi possiamo
bisogno di vedere disco a fare anche the
collector che non era andato in questo
quando lo so perché prova beh comunque
faccio the diamond east che si
confrontano una merda perché gestito
norma lo farò nel prossimo ragazzi spero
il video vi sia piaciuto che un settore
che mi è piaciuto il momento è un mi
piace anche a pace di facebook coniuga
la descrizione giustizia felici
vediamolo prossimo video bello ragazzi